megan is with us in Bakersfield
California hi Megan how are you I'm
gonna reel better than I deserve
how can I help um okay so well I just
have like a pretty weird personality so
I might get all crazy here but we're on
the tail end of baby step two we only
have like 36 hundred dollars to pay off
one bill and my husband is finishing the
last of his prerequisites to start
nursing school and we plan on just
bankrolling that the whole way through
with help from parents and we don't want
to take out loans good so I am more of
like a future planner like I don't like
to thank just like where we're going to
be in five years like I'm thinking more
about the mortgage when my husband
graduates because a lot of a much larger
income and I have heard a lot about like
prepaid interest or prepaid principal
and they don't really understand how
that works like I was watching the pill
method and then he was talking about
taking out loans and I was like this
guy's a nut so I'm listening to it but
that's kind of where I was at was how do
you principal payments work yeah it
makes it sound like there's some kind of
a magic to it it there's no magic to it
at all
you take the interest rate of your
mortgage and you multiply it R divided
by 12 okay and you multiply that times
the outstanding balance that month that
is the interest charged that month does
that make sense
mm-hmm and the rest of your payment goes
towards principle and so let's just make
up some easy numbers let's say 6%
interest rate which would be very well
issues 3% interest rate okay that's
current that's a quarter of a percent
0.25 per month if you divide 3 percent
by 12 okay you'll get a quarter of a
percent per month and then so if you had
a hundred thousand dollar loan just to
make the numbers real round just because
it's a good it's a good lesson to walk
through you'd say 0.025 is your
oops I did that is 0.025 still not doing
that right a hundred thousand but to me
things in calculator one time point zero
to five there we go okay there we go 250
bucks I should be able do that my head
alright anyway
$250 of your payment that month if you
have a hundred thousand dollar balance
at three percent would go towards
interest right okay now let's say your
payment was three hundred and fifty
dollars
it wouldn't be let's say it's four
hundred and fifty dollars okay okay and
then so 250 went to interest the other
two hundred dollars would pay the
$100,000
does that make sense yeah the next month
your interest is calculated on ninety
eight thousand eight hundred dollars at
a quarter and so instead of being two
hundred fifty dollars I make up a number
let's say it's two hundred forty seven
dollars okay but your name your payment
is still four hundred dollars but a
little bit less went to interest so a
little bit more goes to principal so
instead of paying two hundred dollars
towards principal the next month in our
example it might be two hundred and
three dollars you follow me okay so
every time you pay principal that makes
your next payment more of it go towards
principal less towards interest so it's
like say for example I was gifted a
thousand dollars for I don't know just
being amazing and somebody and we went
and put that on the principal yes would
that change our payment the next month
no or what he meant stays the same
it changes the amount of interest would
go down because you're going to be
charged interest on a thousand dollars
less you're not paying interest on that
thousand dollars anymore okay and so it
would cause your your payment would stay
exactly the same but more of your
payment would go towards principal oh
okay you don't have as high an interest
charge because you don't have as high up
balance your interest is calculated on
the balance each month you pay your
interest rate only on what's outstanding
so if you throw 10,000 bucks at a
mortgage you don't pay interest the next
month on that $10,000 oh it saves you
the interest on that $10,000 your
payment stays the same so a lot more of
your payment would then go towards
principle the following month than it
did before so that's why sometimes
people say oh you know I don't wanna
I've already paid all the interest so I
don't want to pay my mortgage off
because I don't have already paid all
the interest upfront
no you didn't you only pay interest on
what's outstanding and once you've paid
on the mortgage for years and years and
years and you paid the principal down
your payment is still the same much much
more of your payment goes towards
principle after 15 years in a 30-year
mortgage then at the 28th year of a
30-year mortgage exactly okay yeah this
is the kind of stuff that they should
teach in high school because nobody
taught me this yeah that's exactly right
well good news is 36% of the high
schools in America now carry a Dave
Ramsey high school curriculum called
foundations and personal finance so
we've got a little over a third of them
but we got the other two-thirds to go so
but you're exactly right
that's called a simple interest
calculation that I just walk through
with you but that's how any mortgage is
calculated have you ever seen the tables
printed out on a mortgage payment where
it shows the columns and shows your
payment and shows how much is going to
interest how much is going to principal
and you slide your finger down you're
down the page you're like wow a whole
lot more after paying you know 120
payments paying 10 years a whole lot
more of its going towards principal than
interest you follow me yeah if you've
ever seen that so what happens is if you
want to do this easy without having to
do the raw math if you pay $10,000 on
your balance you just slide your finger
down the outstanding balance and your
own payment number 37 when you did it
then you pay $10,000 then you're going
to drop down it might be looking more
like payment number 61 is going to be
your next payment you're just knocking
out chunks of payments it's going to be
calculated like payments
t1 whatever wherever the balance is
closest to the new balance after you
paid your 10,000 bucks down it's an item
that really helps a lot I was super
worried about it because I really want
to get it paid off within like 10 years
after he graduates
yeah that's why throwing money at the
mortgage early and often when you get to
baby step six is so important if you but
it's also why you don't need to do more
than once a month because they only
recalculate once a month the payments
are monthly payments and so if you send
for payments in a month it doesn't
change the math at all now they all go
towards principle but you might as well
just send one check and so I've seen
these groups with these supposed systems
that they've gotten all this BS where
you just start sending payments and you
don't want it you want to send one a
week and now it doesn't work because the
calculation is done once a month it is
1/12 of the interest the annual interest
rate per month it is not a daily or a
weekly calculation on mortgages now some
credit cards are calculated daily and
some are calculated twice or three times
or four times a month so they're a
little different but I think it's
calculated once a month paying on it
more than once a month does not change
the math do you understand yeah cool
what's good to talk to you thank you for
calling you that's a good question hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
and so you have to break the cycle you
have to flip this thing on its head and
make it behave you've got to get so
fired up and wired up that you're broke
friends think you've lost your mind
you